we're going to offer the following deal
if you've been in america for more than
five years
if you have children who are american
citizens or legal residents
if you register pass a criminal
background check and you're willing to
pay your fair share of taxes
you'll be able to apply to stay in this
country temporarily without fear of
deportation
you can come out of the shadows and get
right with the law
that's what this deal is
now let's be clear
about what it isn't
this deal does not apply to anyone who
has come to this country recently
it does not apply to anyone who might
come to america illegally in the future
it does not grant citizenship or the
right to stay here permanently or offer
the same benefits that citizens receive
only congress can do that
all we're saying is we're not going to
deport you
i know some of the critics of this
action call it amnesty
well it's not
amnesty is the immigration system we
have today
millions of people who live here without
paying their taxes or playing by the
rules while politicians use the issue to
scare people and whip up votes at
election time
that's the real amnesty
leaving this broken system the way it is
nasa amnesty would be unfair
mass deportation would be both
impossible and contrary to our character
what i'm describing is accountability
a common sense middle ground approach
if you meet the criteria you can come
out of the shadows and get right with
the law
if you're a criminal you'll be deported
if you plan to enter the u.s illegally
your chances of getting caught and sent
back just went up